hi there everyone i'm brady who makes
the number five videos and i've come to
the other side of the camera i'm here at
the royal society where we make
objectivity videos usually with keith
the head librarian here keith is going
to show matt and i around a few things
we want to have a look at and today we
want to talk about prime numbers i'm
very excited we're like we don't mind a
prime number on it i can go a prime
number every day yeah we don't mind they
they're quite a theme on number five and
this always seems quite modern we're
always talking about computers and all
these sort of things yeah modern
innovations and prime numbers yeah all
these super computers crunching things
and gimp's projects and that but you
always say that people have been
fascinated with prime numbers forever no
it's true we always talk about really
modern prime numbers that we're doing or
we talk about the ancient greeks right
and so it seems to be like no one did
anything for thousands of years and then
suddenly people invented computers and
we were often racing and so i believe
keith is going to fill in a few of the
games we have plenty of material in
between yes so let's have a look at some
of that so here in the royal study
archives this is from 1847.
are these
papers people have like sent to the
royal society or that that's right so
they've sent them into the royal society
and on the whole they're not published
so they're the ones
they didn't
but they kept them all they did which is
rather great because we can see exactly
what people were writing about even the
even the stuff that was a bit you know
slightly the rubbish look at this matt
look at this is this specifically maths
themed this book or this just the order
they arrived this is all topics so it
could be this oh you're going too fast
this is just how much amazing stuff
there is here i know this is exciting
for you but let's get to this paper here
this has been written this is from 1847
the right honourable sir frederick
pollock chief baron of the ex-checker oh
so he's in charge of the country's
finances and the title is on certain
properties of prime numbers
usually these papers start with a bit of
a history behind the topic also
previously on yeah so so previously on
pine numbers here are some of the key
papers he's citing and i can see in the
following year here lagrange so he's
quoting things that have been published
he's waffling he's waffling and then
then we're getting interested this is
like this is like an early number file
video
this is i like to yeah it probably could
do with editing down so it is a lot like
another
yeah there we go there we go so yeah oh
okay so he's found certain numbers so
720 if you add the cube numbers
to it
they're all multiples of seven and he's
found another number two two four zero
if you add the cube numbers to that it's
always a multiple of okay or add or
subtract
oh that's true they're always within a
cube number of a multiple of nine i mean
this is mo this is early recreational
mathematics so he's gone you know what
the country can do with its own finances
for a moment i want to find base numbers
which are always within a cube's reach
of a multiple that is brilliant well the
nation is safe in his hand
i like this guy i like the kind of gym
we've got another paper here w shanks
reciprocals of prime numbers okay so
remarks connected with the number of
figures in the periods of reciprocals of
the prime numbers
1873 1873. okay so he's got the inverse
of these numbers and then he's got 10 to
a massive power at the top and then he's
equated that to something and he's
talking about periods in the res
this reminds me a lot of emails i get
well probably like a lot of those emails
you get it says here at the end this was
read but not published is this an early
crank email it didn't get printed it
didn't make it to press keith is just
common for people to put their heart and
soul into something send it to the royal
society and yeah i mean it ends up in a
number of videos
we still have cranks files and they're
absolutely wonderful it's when we
surveyed the archives some years ago for
things that should be kept and studied
cranks files were the top of the fellows
list because they're so brilliant such
an insight yeah they tend to reflect
what's going on in popular science at a
particular time it's so good because i
get emails from people who claim they've
discovered a new pattern in the prime
numbers it's great to know that has been
going on for centuries yep oh yes here
we go so another
well what era is oh i see numbers
already this is the one where are we in
this is what i wanted to show you oh my
goodness so this is called
rods to find prime numbers rods to find
prime numbers so there's we've got no
paper we've got no explanation it's just
that one sheet okay they've run the
primes across the top of these ones
right all the prime's up below 100 it
seems and they've ignored the annoying
low primes which never behave i don't
spot any other patterns in the numbers
underneath them well how about we take a
picture of it and we'll put up on our
website
it just goes to show prime numbers
not just ancient times not just modern
computers basically it's always prime
number time
now
if you want to see more things like this
papers objects old-fashioned things also
more of matt here in the royal society
we've done another video check out
objectivity we've got loads and loads of
videos going through all of these stacks
of archives looking at all these amazing
things here at the royal society if you
found this mildly interesting you're
going to love objectivity
that is in the possession of
tabby or her cat
and then he signs out i have the honor
to be
dear sir your most obedient humble
servant
philip rashly
hero girl
amateur scientist hero for the ages